frau lindemann kennen sie existenzangst
haben sie in diesen tagen existenzangst
ja doch schon mein job da steht ja schon
besoffen spiel jetzt wenn uns der ölhahn
zugedreht wird und pro fall wenn das
können wir nicht und dann merke ich
natürlich auch weil alles teurer wird
die lebensmittel und ja die mieten die
gasanlage was legen sie zurück wie
bereiten sie sich darauf vor auf den
herbst auf dem markt gar nichts
zurücklegen ich lebe gerade schon vor
meinen ersparnissen muss ich ehrlich
sagen das heißt an der stelle also
sparen sparen sparen energie sparen aber
geld sparen können sie gar nicht wie
spüren sie diese angst bereitet ihnen
das schlaflose nächte wie sprechen sie
mit den kindern darüber
ich habe tatsächlich schon vorräte
angelegt für den fall dass war eine
dunkel flotte haben und zwei wochen oder
so überhaupt keinen strom mehr kriegen
wird häufig das war vor zwei wochen war
zu essen haben und in kleinen gaskocher
meine kinder zeigen den vogel die lachen
mich aus ja aber wir werden ja sehen wer
sarrazin wie konnte das in deutschland
so weit kommen dass jemand der arbeitet
über zwei jahrzehnte in der raffinerie
in schwedt alleinerziehende mutter
mitten im arbeitsleben hat angst um
ihren kleinen wohlstand hat existenz ist
ja dass wir dass sie angst haben dass
das ist zu verstehen das ist ganz klar
das hätte ich auch in ihrer situation
letztlich muss ich muss sich die politik
fragen wie kann sie muss ja immer fragen
wie kam es dort hin und wie kann man dem
einzelnen helfen dass man zwei
unterschiedliche waren es redet aber wie
kam es dorthin hat man noch mal die
zahlen angeschaut werden sie mich
eingeladen hatten also der deutschland
hat ja beim beim bezug von erdgas
keinerlei preis der vorteile gehabt
gegenüber anderen ländern wir haben in
den letzten 15 jahren exakt das bezahlt
was andere auch zahlen das heißt wenn
wir unser wenn wir unser erdgas woanders
bezogen hätten in anderen strukturen wie
frankreich spanien wer andere länder
hätten wir das selber gezahlt und hätten
jetzt keine not und hier hat wo die
deutsche politik insgesamt versagt
nämlich alle die die
unkritisch eben gesagt haben na ja wenn
das gas ankommt ist doch ok und die
leitung ist doch da und die werden schon
nicht auf unser geld fest die haben sich
alle gehören das aufzuarbeiten wochen
eine eigene sendung jetzt ist man da wo
man ist und dann die nächste frage was
hätte die politik tun können als stern
als der also einmarsch kam in die
ukraine und da muss ich sagen sie hatte
keine andere wahl abzusagen mit diesem
land dass von diesem mann geführt wird
treiben wir kein handel mehr alles
andere wäre der politik ganz unmöglich
zu sagen sie diskutieren wir hier noch
eine absage weil ich bei dem dritten
punkt wie man mit der situation umgeht
und da beginnt also meine kritik an der
augenblicklichen politik sie war davor
beim vorfeld daran sind viele schuld das
ist vergossene milch und jetzt wäre für
mich ganz klar man muss ja muss ja man
muss ja alle drei gruppen unterscheiden
jemand wie mich mit seinem
einfamilienhaus einem vernünftigen
pensions- einkommen es ist natürlich oft
auch dann sehr ärgerlich wenn die
gasrechnung steigt aber es ist nicht
existenziell und ich musste es auch
jetzt darauf nicht verzichten
und das gilt für also viele millionen
deutsche und am ganz unteren ende der
gesellschaft gilt für also sieben
millionen empfänger von grundsicherung
ist das auch nicht erzählt das hat der
staat letztlich das erdgas und in der
mitte ist eine gruppe für die ist das
existenziell und denen muss man helfen
und zwar
wir haben 80 millionen deutsche ich
würde mal sagen zehn millionen mit 10 7
millionen
jetzt kann man den einkommen sieht
ortschaft ganz unten in der
einkommensskala grundsicherung dann also
zehn millionen das sind also das sind
jetzt wie sie die alleinerziehende mit
drei kindern kein so wahnsinnig hohes
einkommen das sind der rentner die kurz
über der grundsicherung liegen
es gibt viele viele unterschiedliche
fälle und da muss man helfen und muss so
helfen dass man die jetzt nicht am gas
sparen hindert also es ist falsch dass
gas zu subventionieren jeder soll
möglichst viel gas aktiv einsparen muss
ihnen helfen durch durch also durch also
allgemeine einkommens hilfen die kann
man
doch kann man einbauen ins wohngeld das
kann man einbauen in die einkommensteuer
lone star da gibt es unterschiedliche
wege ich würde sagen eine familie iks
die eben jetzt durch benzin und energie
im monat nach der 600 600 euro
mehrausgaben hat der müsste man eben
sagen damit jedenfalls jetzt jetzt meint
gegen 50 prozent vom staat abgenommen
damit auch noch was übrig bleibt damit
auch das preis bleibt und das geht nur
durch absolute durch einkommen zu helfen
was jetzt passiert mehrwertsteuer ich
lass mir einen tiefen hass ich habe wir
haben in unseren in unserem haus in der
flotten burg 25.000 kwh verbrauchen und
die würdige geht hat und jetzt hatte ich
plötzlich stadt statt statt also 19
prozent nur 7 prozent sie würden
eigentlich hier eine rede man direkt im
rhein so weit geht jetzt die
freundschaft nicht ich kenne ja noch gar
nicht aber ich würde mal sagen dass der
staat wie das gibt finde ich
einigermaßen upload